[Musique]
votre lafontaine a raconté l'histoire
d'une chatte métamorphosée en femme il
est arrivé à la ferme une histoire bien
plus extraordinaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
encore une journée est finie oui
évidemment on ne commencera une autre
pas pareil à sa douche
elle sera pareil parce que nous serons
pareil c'est profond ce que je dis là
oui tu me comprends pas moi-même c'est
dommage mon fils va changer
[Musique]
je sais pas ce que voudraient être à
cheval
je répète dans sa peau une crinière
une cancre m
et je courrai plus fort commerçants moi
je n'en demande pas tant
je me contenterai d'être un âne gris
avec une tache blanche sur la tête
j'aurai quatre sabots si j'aurai deux
grandes oreilles que je crée bouger pour
m'amuser et surtout j'aurai des yeux
doux très beau cheval jours à prévert
une charrette acajou verni noir et les
yeux bleus
madame c'est plus gentil
je promènerait des petites filles
[Musique]
alors comment ça une nuit étrange est
terrible elle était noire épaisse et on
entendit dans ces ténèbres un bruit de
chaîne et une espèce de petite musique
de poche sans oublier le sifflement de
la tempête
quoique le vent ne se fût pas levée mais
le lendemain matin tout s'apaisa et
comme j'en avais l'habitude
j'allais avec le chien réveiller les
petites
c'est l'heure d'aller réveiller les
petites à c'est un spectacle dont je ne
me lasse pas moi non plus leurs têtes
blondes sur leur aurait dit c'est 8
heures ça nous ennuie de vous réveiller
ou faut pas parler en mon dieu on a dû
avoir une hallucination
qu'est ce que c'est une hallucination
c'est difficile à expliquer ou alors
c'est un mystère qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un mystère c'est impossible a
expliqué que faut-il faire quand une
chose est impossible a expliqué le mieux
c'est de ne pas s'en occuper et bien
oui tu marie-mai et toi ou études et
fine
mais je suis la fille mais je vois
cheval dans ton lit et - grid retient
nous avons été changé oui d'ailleurs
nous voulions les trois tu sais j'avais
du sort mais ici on ne va plus pouvoir
mettre nos rangs ne t'inquiète pas tu as
beau poil et si tu voyais pas qu'une
hier je crois que tu serais contente
qu'il toi que tes oreilles super gt yeux
clos et plus tendres qu'une petite fille
n'en n'a tout de même je suis un peu
ennuyé
moi aussi de toute façon ne restons pas
ici je crois que ce n'est plus notre
place
[Musique]
où sont les petites elles devraient être
levés
elle tend sûrement levée pourrait
devenir nous embrasser ses vraies belles
filles marinette
qu'attendez vous pour venir embrasser
vos parents qu'est ce que c'est que j'ai
bête et qui ne sont pas nous je suis
delphine et mon art inc
qu'est ce que vous me chanter là vous
êtes bêtes
la mère ne croyait pas si bien vivre ses
filles étaient devenus non pas bête mais
des bêtes car les bêtes ne sont pas
bêtes comme vous pouvez le constater en
m'écoutant mais ayant reconnu la
métamorphose à défaut de pouvoir
l'expliquer les parents durent prendre
des décisions et ne peuvent plus coucher
dans leur chambre ils peuvent pas non
plus manger avec nous tu crois ça dépend
de ce qu'elle mange pour le déjeuner
bien beau rôti de veau aux champignons
est-ce que ça me fait envie non de la
viande quelle horreur
on aimerait lui la voile vous voulez
dire des flocons d'avoine non quoi
développer dans ces conditions il faut
les mettre à l'écurie aller à l'écurie
je vous rejoins les dommages ce sont de
belles bêtes
pourquoi dommage parce que ce sont nos
fils
tant qu'à faire j'aime autant être la
mère de deux jolies bête évidemment et
on pourra pas leur demander de
travailler comme des bêtes
évidemment elles doivent tenir leur rang
la star a donc les deux petites à
l'écurie avec une litière fraîcheur
atelier bien garnie de foin cdu fois
l'année dernière j'ai trouvé des tic ou
dans la voix on à dire à papa
mais quand il faisait beau elle ne
restait pas à l'écurie
l'avantagé c'est qu'on t'a plu à l'école
oui dans mon avantage remarque ce
n'était pas tellement ennuyeuse l'école
non on s'amusait bien après on va au
près mais tu qu'on aille le voir encore
goûté qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on fasse
doute
on
[Musique]
tu te souviens c'est dans ce trou quand
je vais jouer à la balle tu te souviens
un jour je vais me mazars qui nous a
mordu les mollets nous a fait mal oui
c'était le bon temps
les heures des repas était toujours un
peu triste
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites là encore ça
nous fait plaisir de vous voir vous
n'aimerez bien être assise à petit vous
autour de la table on n'aurait jamais vu
ça et puis vous qu'à seriez les chaises
l'écouté ça m'énerve de vous sentir dans
mon dos pendant notre repas manger votre
fonds à l'écurie et ne passez pas votre
temps à ne rien faire c'est pas un
exemple pour les vrais animaux et de ce
jour là les pauvres petites ne vire plus
guère leurs parents que lorsqu'il leur
apportait à manger ou refuser leur
litière
mais un certain dimanche se déroule à
une scène surprenante
bonjour et bon à longueuil vraie salle
alfred la nièce harriet braun allez vous
me semblez de petit j'étais venu d
embrasser et leur offrir des mois c'est
bon vous n'avez pas de chance et elles
sont justement chez leur tante jeanne
qu'est ce que tu dit elle mais dites moi
vous avez là un beau cheval est un bel
homme je les avais jamais vu et vous ne
m'aviez pas parler dans votre dernière
lettre
y'a pas moi qui sont à l'écurie
je ne sais pas monter à cheval avec moi
ne vous inquiétez pas et moi je
porterais votre parapluie est bien
aimable jeu de super fatigué ayant
laissé votre ampli tranquille où allez
vous en au fond du pré montrant que le
musée à ses vues pourquoi dites vous vos
troubles quand vous leur parlez de moi
parce qu'ici tout les bacs sont de la
famille bon eh bien quand médias se
reviendront de chez leur tante jeanne
vous leur donnerez l'ombre mecs il faut
que je me sens on pouvait pas dire la
vérité alfred ils n'auraient pas compris
tu as raison qui pourrait comprendre
on voudrait nous brasser les montre que
déjà vu anne avec un bracelet montre le
père avait raison le cheval et l'âne
gris regrettèrent une nouvelle fois de
n'être plus de petites filles
mais les choses empiraient encore cette
année là la récolte fut mauvaise la
provision de foin diminue 1 et on la
réserva pour les boeufs et les vaches
qui méritaient des soins particuliers
soit par leur travail soit à cause de
leur anglais mais ce ne fut pas tout une
fois dans la grange et les prêts non
plus un brin d'herbe falloir vendre les
bêtes
quelle bête si c'était pas nos fils je
voudrais bien l'année le cheval il
rapporte rien il travaille pas on peut
tout de même pas vendre nos filles
ballon je vais vendre les boeufs mais il
faudra que les petites fassent leur
travail
vous êtes lié à une charrue à l'autre '
qu'ils ont c'est déjà mieux pour un âne
ou pour un sauvage
c'est vrai en plus on risque de mourir
bientôt quand même de mourir de trouver
allez vous avancez paresseuse mais c'est
de marcher droit
vous appelez ça un silence il est aussi
tordu qu'un serpent
mais qu'est ce qu'on vous a appris à
l'école on apprend dans petite fille a
tiré de charrue alors les petites filles
n'ont qu'à rester et petites filles
allaient les incidents de ce genre se
multiplièrent une autre fois
maintenant je me suis enrhumé un âne ne
peut pas s'enrhumer ailleurs jeté ennuis
au village sous la pluie
toi tu avais un parapluie tu vois un âne
arrivée au village à part a plu à la
pâte
quand j'étais une petite fille tu ne
m'aurait pas laisser mouillé ainsi s'il
fallait prendre avec les ânes les
précautions comprend avec les enfants on
n'en sortirait pas la retrouver ta soeur
édiles 8e souffler dessus ça très chaud
fera
et voilà ce qu'elle m'a répondu ce qui
m'étonne c'est que les autres adaptative
d'être mené s'est durement c'est toute
une révolution à faire et les choses
allèrent ainsi tant bien que mal
jusqu'au jour où elle a l'air bien plus
mal
ce jour là l'homme arriva à la ferme
bonjour je suis marchand mesure où je
veux pas acheter de cheval mais je ne
veux pas vous en vente je voudrais vous
en achetez vous avez vu l'autre jour au
village votre charrette été tirée par un
assez beau cheval il ferait bien mon
affaire ce cheval n'est pas à vendre
si je vous en offrait 100 milles qui
sans mines ni 200000 si je disais 300
mille noms et 400000 et 500000 mari
d'être il ya un homme qui veut acheter
je ne vous pas vos parents ont du mal à
croire que vous soyez vraiment leur
fille
pourquoi d'abord parce que ça les
arrange
on croit toujours ce qui vous arrange si
vous n'êtes pas leur fille ils peuvent
vous faire travailler vous taper dessus
vous vendre je ne veux pas quitter des
filles
alors comme l'acheteur va vouloir te
voir tu n'as qu'à faire semblant de
boiter ya maldonne
je n'avais pas remarqué que votre cheval
boiteux c'est un caprice ce matin il
était en corse un des quatre pattes
s'il est capricieux c'est encore pire ma
femme déjà et capricieuse ça suffit à
mon poids donné la vie le marchand son
fût ce sens affûté marinette mais ce qui
reste est très grave c'est que le chien
avait dit vrai bon dit carl tu as des
traits de boîte est un défi je suis le
père d'un cheval et de l'âne aux si vous
imaginiez que ma femme et moi acceptions
un mensonge aussi so he détrompez vous
la vérité est que vous êtes deux animaux
et même pas des amis mon modèle
maintenant est ce que tu crois aussi que
nous ne sommes pas des filles vous êtes
de bonne bête mais je sais bien que vous
ne pouvez pas être mes filles
à l'heure où je vous fais si ce n'est
pas nous vous voilà les drôles de
parents qui vont disparaître leur fille
ne s'en soucie pas davantage les avez
vous seulement chercher dans le puits
dans la mare dans les bois les parents
ne sûr que répondre et comment certains
être malheureux ce n'était pas de
mauvais parents mais la situation les
dépasser mettez vous à leur place et les
petites était malheureuse aussi et dieu
sait comment cela aurait fini si un
matin
[Musique]
je verrai attelé la charrue ya pas de
quoi pleurer tu vois toi aussi tu es au
travail le cheval est l'ange n'en
dormais encore
[Musique]
[Rires]
le
[Musique]
et
là
bonjour y a bien dormi oui naturellement
vous pensez les petites ont rêvé cette
histoire est ce pas